H love you guys uh today we're going to
do a programming for uh for vet C8 with
the key looking like that but there will
be for all the keys that looks like that
um I'm going to show you how to do it
from in and out so to launch the dealer
tool we're just going to launch it from
Google Chrome but we're going to be
using the techline
connect so we're just going to go
to AC
[Music]
TDS and when you get
here you're just going to log into
your AC Delco
account so I just going to log into
mine and I'm just going to put the
verification code that they've been
sending
me and we just going to do log in
after when we are here we're just going
to scroll all the way
down we're going to hit I have red we're
going to hit
agree and then here you need going to
need to
buy the subscription but
uh we should have here a subscription
ready to
[Music]
go so you're going to hit View after you
bought one subscription you're going to
do
[Music]
advin and now it looks like it's
launching so we just fixed our internet
problem so now it's going to launch the
TLC going to put the car in on position
so we're just going to press the push to
start for 12 seconds
car is on
on so you see it
off so after you get to this
interface sorry for a little
[Music]
darness so on this screen we're just
going to enter the VIN right here we
just going to hit select
so it shows us the
car and then we can go
here and press the
SP2 to load
this and then
here we're going to leave
it and reprogram and we're going to hit
the next right
here I have a lot of sun on my screen so
I barely see it sorry about that
guys so after I read the vehicle data
we're just going to go to immobilizer
learn which is right
here sorry about that know what was it
so when you're going to press mobilizer
learn you can just hit next right here
in the
bottom so here it's going to tell us
that it's going to take the one of the
VIN slots which it's okay it's going to
cost 45 bucks each Vin uh to buy uh from
them and I think you can buy more maybe
for lower rate
but basically gives you 24 uh months of
uh
or I think 24 months of uh subscription
it's in the AC doco website and this is
where we get in got in
from and here we just going to
go program transponder or remote
key and we're going to do add so we just
adding key and then then we just going
to hit
next please make sure the ignition is on
engine is
off
um if it's an OS so you're just going to
do what it does tells you
here so we're just going to hit next on
that please close driver door and place
next just going to hit next on
that and now it's going to be the timer
uh going by it's that 12 minutes of wait
so we're just going to wait with that
and we're going to be with you uh when
we get closer to the end of this kind
thing okay so you guys uh 10 minutes uh
almost passed uh we have the new key we
can already place it in the back bottom
of the cup
holder and again you can find that on
the owner manual on every GM model very
simple they show you a picture of that
so we're just going to wait for that to
finish so number of keys learned is two
uh you do would you like to learn the
keys we're just going to hit the yes on
the bottom over there insert the key
into the slot and press
next press the push start button so
we're just going to press the push start
button
and ready for
key3 and we can press the push start
button
once and we can try to
see going to hit
next so it doesn't get the key so we
just get to
try it
again so we place the key on the back of
the bottom cup
holder and we're going to hit yes insert
the new key and we're going to hit
yes press the start
button and we're going to hit next
[Applause]
and we're going to do it
again and we're going to push the push
start and we're going to hit
next wait for 3
seconds you insert the new key and press
the push
button okay ready for key number four so
we placed it on the front cup holder and
it seems like it that it so we can
do small test and see that it's already
learned I always like to do that because
if not he want to stay in programming so
you can do the next one so we don't want
to do more keys we're just going to hit
no down down there and we're going to
play press the push start for 16
[Music]
seconds see how it says learning Fe
complete over there on the
right just going to wait a couple more
seconds and we're going to let go and
we're going to hit next
here now we're just going to wait 15
seconds
and now we're going to wait
another 6
seconds and then one
more
waiting so we can shut the ignition
off he wants us to open and close the
driver
doors um we're not going to do that
obviously
it's a modified
doors and I don't feel like doing that
now so we're just going to hit next and
we're going to wait a minute and a
half uh but basically this is how uh you
guys can uh perform all the new GM style
keys that look like this knife shaped
can of that will be the easier
faster reliable solution uh just make
sure you have a good internet
connection v200 will be good for Fords
and GM for this
manner uh good thing about GM that you
can just uh purchase the AC Delco but
you don't need to uh provide the D1 for
each
vehicle on the Ford I think you will
need so it's a good benefit about
that and again I'm sorry for the blaring
and uh the sun being on the screen it's
hard for me to see as well I'm just
trying to give you
guys uh Overlook of how it's being done
and the easiest way when you guys think
about dealer tool you can be afraid but
technically it's maybe easier than they
have to Market once in many many
ways so that will be the end of
it and we just is going to make sure
everything works correctly before we
shut it
off so the immobilizer uh complete we
can hit next and then please check if
the engine starts which H key so we can
basically take this
key sit in the
vehicle press the brake and again with
the wing
doors this just
beautiful and we can see that the
immobilizer light on the top goes
away um so the key is completely
done this is how you're going to do
uh those systems from GM I will see you
guys in the next car have a good day and
thank you guys for watching